seit 2011 beteiligt ist das
österreichische bundesheer an der uni
viel mission der vereinten nationen im
libanon
insgesamt nehmen an diesem einsatz
10.000 soldaten aus 38 staaten teil
am 22 mai 2015 wurde bereits das achte
bundesheer kontingent in den libanon
verabschiedet oberst claus ammon der
kommandant der auslandseinsatz basis
eröffnete die verabschiedung und dankte
den soldaten kameraden abschließend
gemeinsam im team wehrte die alle auf
uns zukommenden herausforderungen
bestens meistern
haltet die ausgezeichnete reputation der
bisky binären lebt kameradschaft in der
auftrags erfüllung und in der freizeit
der kommandant der streitkräfte general
leuten und franz reißner dankte den
soldaten dass sie sich für diese
friedenserhaltende mission zur verfügung
gestellt haben
sie können nun mit selbstvertrauen ihren
dienst bei den vereinten nationen
im sinne des weltfriedens antreten
bundesminister magister gerald klug
vertraute darauf dass die soldaten ihre
friedenserhaltende tätigkeit mit
professionalität und engagement
bewältigen werden für ihren persönlichen
einsatz gebührt ihnen mein respekt und
meine anerkennung ich wünsche ihnen
abschließend einen erfolgreichen einsatz
viel soldatenglück und kommen sie wieder
gesund nach hause
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
bundesminister klug übergab die in
sieben des austrian bakteriums der un
des engagement observer force an den
kommandanten der auslandseinsatz basis
zwischen 1974 und 2013 leisteten
österreichische un soldaten auf den
golanhöhen einen wichtigen beitrag für
die stabilität in dieser region